bonjour serai petit merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin sur
arte france qu'est ce que vous attendez
de cette journée de la mobilisation
parce qu'on attend de ces gens là
mobilisation s'est à nouveau des taux de
grévistes très important dans les
établissements et que les sages femmes
puissent s'exprimer largement le fait
que les annonces tente du gouvernement
du ministre vers en août cette
proposition de loi ne résolvent pas du
tout la situation urgente notamment dans
les maternités de la dégradation des
conditions de travail des cuissons prise
en charge et la reconnaissance effective
de de la profession c'est pour ça que la
cgt d'ailleurs n'est pas signataire de
l'accord parce qu'il ya énormément de
points qui nous paraissent peu claires
voire inquiétant pour la profession dans
son ensemble avec elle
dans l'accord dans l'accord déjà il ya
le niveau de revalorisation qui est
largement insuffisant
certes c'est plus que ce que le
gouvernement voulait donner au départ
aux sages femmes à obtenir une prime
d'exercice médicastres revendications
historiques cgt à hauteur de 200
280 euros à peu près par voilà c'est un
premier pas mais c'est largement
insuffisant par rapport à la souris mini
rémunération de cette profession très
exigeante et à très fort taux de
responsabilité donc déjà il ya ce point
là ensuite il ya des éléments sur 20
euros mais je crois que c'était 500
euros non et ben oui mais voilà ces voix
là on touche du doigt le début de la
duperie de ces annonces du gouvernement
et je dirais même de cette proposition
de loi sur la formation des sages-femmes
parce que quand le goût ministre annonce
500 euros pour les sages-femmes non
attention là dedans il ya les 183 euros
du ségur qui sont donc acté depuis
maintenant plus d'un an pour l'ensemble
des professions de sani de la santé et
il arrondit le tout à 500 euros en fait
en rajoutant finalement 300 320 euros
supplémentaires pour le sachem donc non
déjà le chiffre échos ses 320 euros que
nous annonce
le ministre est là dedans il y à une
prime d'exercice médical c'est à dire
c'est pas vraiment la grille de salaire
qui va être valorisé ses 78 euros de
revalorisation sur la grille de salaire
à l'aspect solide statutaire de
reconnaissance de la profession
non c'est une prime une prime ça
s'enlève une prime est ce que ça compte
pour la retraite une prime qu'est ce que
ça va devenir un peu ségur va le pilier
ii du ségur va être mis en place c'est à
dire que ils vont fusionner supprimer
harmoniser comme ils disent les primes
pour les mettre dans une situation pas
pour les rendre dépendants de
l'évaluation professionnelle
individuelle dans la fonction publique
hospitalière c'est toutes les
incertitudes donc déjà je pense que
l'ensemble des organisations même les
signataires de cet accord avec dire au
ministre ce qu'on veut c'est de
l'augmentation sur le salaire sur la
grille de salaires quelque chose de
pérenne parce qu à nouveau parce qu'un
problème notre activité au niveau de
sages femmes en france
oui la situation
la situation de
l'attractivité des sages-femmes en fait
rejoint la situation de l'attractivité
du reste des professions de santé dans
les établissements on est en
sous-effectif chronique les sages femmes
dans nos maternités les postes sont
vacants non pourvus on a plus assez de
candidats de faire les candidatures de
ce prime parce que les conditions de
travail sont sont trop difficile
justement les conditions de travail
dangereuses occasions dangereuses
aujourd'hui donc les si vous voulez
quand les salaires sont à suffisant et
que les conditions de travail se
dégradent en continu et qu'on les voit
année après année se dégrader qu'on n'a
aucune perspective d'amélioration
parce que ce qui manque dans cet accord
aussi c'est des réponses concrètes
immédiates sur les lits qui nous manque
sur les effectifs qui nous mentent sur
nos milliers de collègues contractuels
encore la fonction publique et pour
lesquels le ministre n'a pas annoncé un
plan de titularisation massif alors
qu'on en a besoin au long cours pourquoi
est-ce qu'il n'annonce pas ça pourquoi
ce qui n'annonce pas ça aux achats pour
leur indiquer que en effet il l'entend
il entend les
la colère sur l'aspect immédiat de
dégradation des conditions de prise en
charge des patientes et des conditions
de travail des sachets non ya pas ça
dont il refuse de revoir le ratio des
personnels par rapport à l'activité donc
moi donc la colère elle peut pas
retombée elle peut par tomber parce que
ce refus la
ce refus là il est il est assez
indicatif en fait de
d'une position qui ne le ministre ne
veut pas changer sur la réduction de
l'offre de son en france et notamment la
réduction de l'offre de soins en
maternité à aucun moment il nous dit
j'arrête de fermer des lits de maternité
autrement il nous dit je vais augmenter
les capacités internes - il nous dit je
vais revoir le ratio des sages femmes
par rapport à l'activité dans les
maternités parce qu en effet il faut
l'élever oui toutes et toutes les
organisations sacha me le disent il faut
plus de personnel sa chambre autour des
patientes dans les établissements et la
ministre ne répond pas on a entendu
votre cri d'alarmé strip petit merci
beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes sages femmes à
l'ap-hp est membre de la fédération cgt
santé et action sociale grève donc
aujourd'hui des sages femmes